hung over we got you covered here are
the top 5 hangover cures for the morning
after that raging holiday party you're
welcome number 5 if you need to focus go
for black coffee it works for your dad
it'll work for you there are a lot of
other organic chemicals in there and one
of them in particular has been shown to
reduce liver inflammation and another
chemical in caffeine helps decrease this
uh this chemical in your brain that
causes the headaches and number four
satisfy your desire for fatty foods with
a big juicy burger to absorb the liquor
top it off with a nap and then a beer
it's got a really fluffy buns there's
lots of sugar right in that and it's got
an egg which is actually a special thing
for a hangover it's got a certain amino
acid called cysteine in it that actually
helps you speed up your metabolism of
alcohol huh raw eggs and Worcestershire
sauce this might sound disgusting but
man up and drink it Prairie oysters in
your new best friend now the salt is
going to replace your electrolytes the
Tabasco has capsaicin which is actually
an analgesic or a pain reliever and you
get a little bit of or sister which is
to make your body less acidic and number
two it's a classic for a reason reach
for a Bloody Mary and turn on the game
if there was a picture in the urban
dictionary next to hair of the dog it
should be the Bloody Mary okay finally
if you need to actually get [ __ ] done go
for the charcoal and coconut smoothie
those friends of yours that are laughing
still have a headache coconut water
which is lovely it's very hydrating hey
tree skater it is an activated charcoal
a lovely thing that binds for the toxins
and pharmaceuticals in our body and
helps flush them out if you're drinking
like it's 1999 this holiday season be
sure to share these tips with your
friends and check out all of our
hangover cures at the hangover lab on
the GQ video channel